[Music]
incompetent government
kills people incompetent government
kills people more people died than
needed to die
in covet that's the truth incompetent
government can kill people
this is not a joke and more people died
here
than needed to
governor andrew cuomo meanwhile new
york's attorney general issuing a
bombshell report today
concluding that governor andrew cuomo
under-reported
covet deaths in nursing homes by as much
as 50 percent
if that's the case the number of new
yorkers who died have coveted in nursing
homes
could be as high as 13 000. joining me
right now is a governor who has handled
this pandemic
much differently than any other
certainly than his counterpart in new
york
florida's governor ron desantis governor
it's good to see you tonight thanks very
much for being here
thanks for having me so let's talk about
your approach you just heard governor
uh cuomo in new york and of course the
uh
the situation in new york continues to
be dire
deaths as well as a a real impact
to the city's economy what are you doing
in florida it seems like
so many people are getting up and moving
to florida
uh you can say that again maria we uh
our home sales
year over year 2020 up 24
and a lot of people have been fleeing
lockdowns there's no doubt about it
i think we've done a couple things one
we focus protection on elderly people
rather than trying to shut the entire
society down
so at the front end of the pandemic i
barred hospitals from discharging
coveted patients
back into nursing homes that was able to
save a lot of lives on the front end
and now here on hopefully the back end
of the pandemic our approach to
vaccination is putting seniors first
we're focusing on our 65 and up
population we've reported over 1.1
million seniors that have gotten
a shot in the state of florida that's
almost 25
of our enormous 4.5 million senior
population
and so we think that that's really
important that's where the most risk is
we also though understood we have to
have schools open
so every parent in florida has a right
to send their kid to in-person
instruction
private charter public you name it and
we also say everybody has a right to
work so government local government
can't shut you down
they can't prevent you from do earning a
living they can't prevent businesses
from operating
and the result has been for example in
the month of december
our revenue to the state of florida and
we have very low tax rates
was up 330 million dollars
over the estimated revenue uh people are
coming
they want to do business here they want
to invest here and i'll tell you maria i
run into people that say you know
i was working remotely in whatever state
that lockdown state
and the schools were closed so i said
the heck with this i'm moving to florida
the quality of life's better and i can
send
my kid to in-person instruction and so
you know i think that we've understood
covid's real you focus on your elderly
population
but you can't run your society into the
ground kids need to be in school
people need to be able to earn a living
something was
something that president trump said over
and over again the the cure
cannot be worse than the actual issue
and we have we have
graphics here that show how well florida
is doing you have been open since may
you had
some limitations in september but you
got rid of them
you you also as you said schools are
open and hospitalizations per million
are down relative to california which is
spiking
and new york and then we look at the
number of daily cases
as well as the unemployment rate which
is uh better than
than new york and california tell me how
you're handling this
on a practical level you did have a
shutdown
but the massive mandates uh you you've
removed
well i think the you know the sentiment
that cure can't be worse than disease i
agree with that but what i came to
understand
with the evidence was lockdowns don't
cure anything
even putting aside the economy lockdowns
don't work they haven't worked to stop
the spread
as you say places like california has
been the most locked down
they've had higher cases mortality and
hospitalizations per capita than us
over the last three months uh and so it
doesn't work and so we understood that
uh we also wanted to trust people to
make make decisions and and take the
proper precautions
but that is really the way to do it and
i think that the states of florida
we have one of the oldest populations in
the country second oldest population
uh and yet our mortality per capita for
the whole pandemic
is 26th in the country 25 other states
many of them lockdown states and many of
them have younger populations and yet
they have higher per capita
mortality and so i think that those
lockdowns were not evidence-based
and i think that they were mistakes and
we obviously went a different direction
and so
we're doing consequently we're doing
better i think we're going to come out
of this
uh faster than some other other states
may do it
and and i think you know one of the
things maria people tell me when they
visit from lockdown states is
they're like you know people are just
happier down in florida
because you don't have the weight of the
lockdown weighing everybody down
and yet governor the white house is
attacking florida for the vaccine
distribution talk a little about that
jen pasake
told reporters on monday the state had
only distributed about 50 percent
of its vaccines what's your take there
during that press conference
they were addressing you when you're
approached specifically to reporters
yeah completely disingenuous so what she
said was they've only administered 54
percent
well what she didn't say is the ones
that haven't been administered
are going to be administered on schedule
because it's the second doses for people
so the suggestion she was trying to make
is florida should just be giving away
second doses to people who aren't coming
in for their second dose our elderly
population wants to get the second dose
so you're going to see those second
doses in florida really spike
because people are scheduled for it but
we're not going to squander those second
dose i can tell you
all the first doses that come in we can
rip through in a week and then some
no problem we could probably do two to
three times what we're doing and so
all we were saying is you have all these
things you're saying you're gonna put
federal resources all this and and
create your own sites
it's really not necessary and i think a
lot of democrat governors agree with me
just get more supply of the vaccine
because we were promised
initially we were going to get more up
to this point i can get it into seniors
arms
if we just get more in the shipments at
the same time
dr fauci continues to praise andrew
cuomo in new york
security is a real issue in new york
what do you say to your colleagues in
new york and california
as you're seeing security issues really
skyrocket
shootings murders up as the security of
the state is also an issue with cashless
bail
well right so i think the lockdowns
exacerbate some of these tensions in
society but i think the
uh anti-police movement that we saw over
the summer
i think that's had a devastating effect
and in florida we were very clear
we're standing with our law enforcement
uh we're going to back them and we're
going to actually do a strong
anti-rioting bill
when the legislature meets in march and
so we're looking forward to that
basically we're telling people
uh if you loot you're going to jail uh
if you burn down a building you're going
to jail if you assault a police officer
you're going to jail if you're rioting
you are going to jail we're going to
have zero tolerance for it
governor are you going to be do you have
the capacity to handle this inflow of
new people you just said home sales are
up as much as they are
i know that you have put out a budget
proposal for
2021 and 2022 what is the plan to handle
so much more in terms of population
well we are very strong on
infrastructure we got a great department
of transportation when people
come from some of these other states
that are higher taxes they say
you know your infrastructure's better
and and i pay less in taxes so we take
pride in that
we have a five-year plan we continue to
do that roads and bridges we're also
doing a lot to improve our water
resources and the water infrastructure
so we're thinking ahead we're thinking
term i'm not i can't control where
people decide to live
but if people are coming you know we
want to be able to to accommodate folks
governor we'll be watching it all thanks
so much great to see you tonight
thank you